what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and it
looks like today we might have an
actual release date for the trailer for
spider-man no way home
and it looks like we even have a slight
description of the teaser trailer and
what to
expect from it we have a couple of
different accounts two very
reputable accounts claiming that they
know when the trailer is going to come
and the way that they claim they know
the trailer is coming is very legitimate
so the reports of these two people that
we'll dive into in just a bit
combined with the fact that sony has
started to change some of their
background banners on their official
youtube pages and twitter accounts and
the fact that we are starting to get
merchandise for spiderman no way home
all combined
lead us to believe that we do indeed
know when the trailer is coming and not
only that but it looks like we also may
know what happens in the very beginning
of spider-man no way home which of
course i'll go over as well
also a quick reminder that i will be
announcing the stormbreaker giveaway
winner today
look out for a community post by me or a
video
later on in the day today posting who
the winner is
so some of you may have heard about the
instagram account
comic book savage i got a lot of
different dms about this instagram
account and on this person's instagram
they said my friend who works at a local
movie theater just confirmed
they got the no way home teaser trailer
it's 100
dropping tuesday and coincidentally
tuesday
tomorrow is tom holland's birthday so it
seems like we may have been accurate in
our thinkings that marvel and sony were
indeed going to drop the trailer on tom
holland's birthday
just like they did for shanghai and the
legends of the ten
rings teaser trailer they dropped it on
sima leo's birthday who of course is
playing chongqi
however there are some other reports
that state that yes the theaters do have
the trailer but it might not be coming
on tuesday
this account may have just heard that
yes the theaters have the trailer and
could have
assumed that it is dropping tuesday just
because
that's tom holland's birthday but
another reputable account which i'll
talk about in just a bit
did say that the trailer is in however
we might not get it for another couple
of weeks
now i did a little bit of digging about
this instagram account and it looks like
they're actually followed by
jamie foxx himself so that definitely
adds some credibility
but i think what really makes this
report credible is the fact that this
person isn't the only person reporting
this
skyler schuler over at the dis insider a
very
reputable site and podcast has also
confirmed this to be true
he posted a screenshot of a text message
conversation between him and his
friend who works at a theater as well
skyler tweeted this out and said
had to ask a good friend spider-man no
way home he asked his friend in the
theater if they have the trailer end and
he replied with one sec i gotta pull up
the projections for the week
so it looks like we have it so this is
another confirmation
that the theaters actually have the
spider-man no way home teaser trailer
which means
yes it is dropping and hopefully this
week if comic book savage is correct it
could be dropping tomorrow however
skyler shuler says that it will most
likely come
in two weeks with the release of peter
rabbit so at this point in time the only
thing that's really sure is that
this trailer is going to drop within the
next two weeks which is super exciting
and hey hopefully it drops tomorrow
but this isn't the only news that we got
today we actually have a little bit more
information about the plot of spider-man
no way home
and it seems like we actually have a
description of what to expect from the
teaser trailer which i'll talk about in
just a second
and before we get into it please allow
me a moment to thank keeps for
sponsoring this video
alright everybody real talk i've seen
the analytics of the demographics of
people who watch my video and i know
that
about 90 of people who watch my videos
are males between
18 and 45. and did you know that two out
of three guys will experience some form
of male pattern baldness by the time
they're 35 years old and the best way to
prevent
hair loss is to do something about it
while you still have hair on your head
left and that's where keeps comes in the
best part about keeps
is that it's super convenient and very
affordable you get treated from home by
an
actual licensed doctor and you have
access to the doctors 24 7 to message
them and ask
questions keeps also has more five-star
reviews than any of its competitors and
hundreds of thousands of men
trust keeps for their hair loss
prevention if you're ready to take
action and prevent hair loss go to
keeps.com
cosmic or click the link in the
description to receive 50
off your first order that's keeps.com
cosmic
so there's a twitter account called no
way home teaser that apparently had a
description of what the teaser trailer
is going to be like they originally
posted the description in spanish but it
has been translated and thank you to my
discord for pointing this out
and this says peter is being sought
after by the fbi for murder
there is a very quick scene of police
breaking into the house with his aunt
there in fear
from what the teaser shows us peter
surrenders and it's very serious what is
going on
almost the entire time peter is living
on the street in what they show in the
trailer but
doctor strange appears the teaser starts
with peter inside some type of
establishment
he takes food and runs away in an alley
it shows a guy from the newspaper
talking about him which i'm presuming is
jj
and then he enters in abandoned shed
then chose his aunt
crying now obviously this translation
isn't a perfect
translation it's not word for word and a
lot is missing from it
but based off of what we do know this
makes a lot of sense because we know
no way home is going to pick up
immediately after the events of
spider-man far from home so that means
peter's identity was just revealed he
was just
framed for murder so it would make sense
that the fbi would be going to his house
where they know he lives
of course doctor strange is widely known
to be in the film so it would make sense
that they would show him
i would not expect tobey maguire or
andrew garfield to make an appearance in
the teaser trailer
so as far as the actual plot of
spider-man no way home is concerned i've
posted a lot of different plot leaks and
rumors and reports on my channel
really anytime something's popped up
that gives us a little bit of
information about the film i've pretty
much reported
and it looks like based off of all the
information that we've seen out there
we know a pretty decent amount about the
movie based on all of this information
things like toby maguire spider-man and
andrew garfield spider-man returning
from their respective universes
into the mcu we've heard that the green
goblin from the sam
raimi tobey maguire universe is going to
be the main villain of this film
and of course we know about other
villains returning like jamie foxx's
electro alfred molina's doc
and more villains essentially almost
making up the sinister six although it's
unclear on whether or not they'll call
them that in the film
so it looks like we have a lot however
it doesn't look like we know
everything which is awesome because we
want to be surprised obviously but
according to
super hero theorist on twitter they say
there are so many things you guys don't
know yet
i pray that sony somehow finds a way to
tape up the faucet to avoid leaks
because this film
really is absolutely bonkers based on
what i've seen
for spider-man fans emotions will run
high when the film drops in december
so this movie is looking like it's
actually going to be very
very big obviously if the spider-verse
is involved with the other two
spider-mans
but it looks like there's a lot more in
store for us that we don't know yet
which is awesome
but speaking of things that we might
actually know already some things i've
talked about
in the past are how the villains end up
in the main mcu timeline in our universe
from their universe
well it looks like we're going to figure
that out in the very beginning of the
film
the twitter user viewer anon who has
been right about multiple leaks in the
past four previous disney plus shows has
stated what to expect in the beginning
of the film which he says
is act one and here's what he had to say
the sinister six are all from other
universes and remember they're dying
specifically they're dying at the hands
of
spider-man then we know that they
somehow end up getting taken from their
respective universes
and into the main mcu which has tom
holland's peter parker spider-man and
the leak says that this causes
great guilt in holland's peter and he
ends up doing something
stupid against doctor strange's orders
now of course we know that doctor
strange is going to be peter's mentor in
the film and of course that makes a lot
of sense because the multiverse is
essentially going to be
breaking or bursting into madness and it
looks like the immediate repercussions
are going to be
for peter parker villains coming into
his universe from other universes where
spider-man not him but other spider-man
have caused them to
essentially die in their respective
universes so peter being the good guy
that he is is going to go against doctor
strange's orders which of course
is going to be don't try to fix anything
from other universes
let me fix that but peter is going to go
against the orders and probably do
something a little bit foolish that's
going to make for a pretty good movie
and perhaps that's why doctor strange
could bring in the other spider-man
but fortunately it looks like we don't
have to wait much longer for the teaser
trailer now i do want to point out that
comic book savage did say the trailer is
going to be on tuesday however skyler
shuler did not specifically say tuesday
he just said that the theaters have the
trailer so hopefully it does come out on
tuesday but if it doesn't it is
definitely coming very soon
probably this week now it would make
sense to come out
on tom holland's birthday that would be
awesome so let's hope that but don't
give up hope if it doesn't come tuesday
in the meantime don't forget to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all of the latest spider-man and
mcu news don't forget to comment below
how excited you are to see the
spider-man noah home trailer don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof